Окупаційна влада Херсонської області оголосила так звану "евакуацію" цивільного населення на лівий берег Дніпра,
назвавши її "добровільним організованим безкоштовним переміщенням".
Таким чином, планується "перемістити" 50-60 тисяч осіб.
Вони, за словами окупаційної влади, зможуть залишитися в регіоні
або за бажання виїхати до Росії, де їм обіцяють видавати сертифікати на житло.
Для того, щоб військові працювали спокійно і не думали про те, що за їхніми спинами стоять мирні мешканці,
потрібно виїхати… і дати можливість військовим зробити свою роботу якісно
і з меншими втратами для мирного населення.
Україна оголосила Росії тотальну війну.
За словами Сальдо, Україна - цитата - "накопичує сили для широкомасштабного наступу"
і нібито має намір зруйнувати греблю Каховської ГЕС.
На думку західних аналітиків, настав вирішальний момент у цій війні до настання зими.
З усіх наступів, проведених українцями, херсонський - найважливіший і вирішальний.
Там росіянам вдалося на початку війни перейти через Дніпро.
Навіть якщо зараз на це не схоже, але теоретично, якщо вони втримають цей плацдарм,
підтягнуть резерви та консолідують позиції взимку, то могли б через Миколаїв піти на Одесу,
позбавивши Україну виходу до моря. Ось чому цей плацдарм такий важливий.
Ще тиждень тому у своєму телеграм-каналі представник окупаційної псевдовлади в Херсоні Кирило Стремоусов
говорив, що ні про яку евакуацію не йдеться.
Самопроголошена влада лише рекомендувала забрати дітей і поїхати на так званий "відпочинок" до Росії.
Ніхто нікого не евакуює. Жодної евакуації немає. Це все робочий формат.
Усі можливості залишити зону ризику - це не евакуація, це можливість рятувати життя.
Тепер тон його заяв різко змінився:
За нашими даними, укрнацисти, яких підштовхує Захід, уже найближчим часом розпочнуть наступ на місто Херсон.
Не виключені обстріли міста Херсона, не виключені обстріли правобережної частини Херсонської області.
Два тижні ми настійливо рекомендуємо покинути правобережну частину Херсонської області.
Попрошу сприйняти мої слова всерйоз як максимально швидку евакуацію.
Місто здавати ми не збираємося. Будемо стояти до кінця. Нацистів у місто ми не пустимо.
Псевдогубернатор захопленого Росією українського регіону Володимир Сальдо
оголосив про переїзд усіх органів окупаційних владних структур на лівий берег Дніпра.
У місцевих пабліках повідомляється про те, що мешканці Херсона отримують SMS-повідомлення
із закликами терміново евакуюватися на лівий берег.
Напередодні генерал Сергій Суровікін дав перше інтерв'ю після свого призначення командувачем
об'єднаного угрупування військ РФ в Україні.
Він заявив, що дії російських військ у Херсоні залежатимуть від військово-тактичної ситуації.
Обстановку у зоні проведення спеціальної військової операції можна охарактеризувати як напружену.
Противник не полишає спроб атакувати позиції російських військ.
Ми будемо виходити з необхідності максимального збереження життя мирного населення
і наших військовослужбовців. Це є для нас пріоритетом.
Будемо діяти усвідомлено, своєчасно, не виключаючи ухвалення найбільш непростих рішень.
Що саме він мав на увазі, Суровікін не уточнив.
Я гадаю, що російські військовокомандувачі, а також Володимир Путін готують громадську думку до того факту,
що російські війська залишать Херсон, щоб уникнути цього третього символічного провалу
російської армії за останні два місяці.
Бо військово це майже неможливо для армії РФ утримати Херсон під своїм контролем.
На думку австрійського аналітика Райснера, це питання також дуже непокоїть російських солдатів,
дислокованих на правому березі Дніпра.
Слід розуміти, що війна ведеться не тільки на полі бою, але і в головах.
І в той момент, коли новий головнокомандувач сказав, що, з одного боку, слід очікувати непростих рішень,
а з іншого - відбувається евакуація населення, простий російський солдат, природно, думає: гаразд, що це означає?
Очевидно, що вони хочуть здати цей плацдарм. І я сам теж хочу врятуватися.
І це той психологічний момент, який, звісно, не можна недооцінювати.
Росія захопила Херсон на початку вторгнення в Україну.
Місто так і залишилося єдиним обласним центром, який їй вдалося окупувати.
Ділянка території праворуч Дніпра теж єдина, захоплена РФ.
Наявність природної водної перешкоди відіграє у нинішньому наступі ЗСУ значну роль.
Щодо Херсона треба мати на увазі, що російські солдати там притиснуті до Дніпра.
І вони знають, що є лише кілька мостів, через які вони можуть перетнути річку, відступаючи.
Якщо Україні вдасться прорив, то можлива паніка на мостах.
Але, можливо, російській армії знову вдасться відбити українську атаку.
Для України ж важливо визволити саме місто Херсон, щоб там перезимувати.
На думку російсько-британського аналітика Петрова,
Росія у військовому плані демонструє себе дедалі неспроможнішою.
Я би сказав, що якщо Росія вже зараз не є військовим банкрутом, то вона явно рухається в цьому напрямку.
Вони вже акумулювали всю високотехнологічну зброю.
Тож, не випадково, що ми бачимо танки й артилерію, яка походить ще з радянських запасів.
Тобто Росія не здатна нині виготовляти високотехнологічну зброю, щоб поповнювати втрачену в ході війни техніку.
Контрнаступальні дії у напрямку Херсона ведуться із серпня.
За даними генштабу, лише за перші дні жовтня ЗСУ звільнили 29 населених пунктів у Херсонській області.